hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to brother wake up now this
is a game where your brother has been
put to sleep under a curse of some sort
what is that do I even want to know what
that is what kind of hello neighbor ass
house is this I'm not harm since you
urban oh thank you alright well ok ok
alright I don't know what that was ok
alright well go to stay here close my
eyes and kiss my ass good-bye hello
who's there who do you think you are
trying to give me a spook I don't even
know what I'm looking for I'm looking
for something but I'm not fine hey I got
a glimpse of a sweet ass [ __ ] bye hello
hi ok let's guess that's how I scream
then I don't know what I'm doing or why
I'm doing it I don't know what I'm doing
or why I'm doing it I have no idea
I gotta find like 4 cogwheels I guess
and what happens Oh [ __ ] god dammit I
don't even have time to get my bearings
in this goddamn game ok so what I need
to do is I need to be very very quiet
probably hide my flashlight because
that's probably what they're okay
alright there's a lot of these guys and
they want a lot of me ok ok ok so they
can't see me unless the lights on so
that's good so long as it
that's Rumble Oh what's this okay
I hear them around but I don't think
that they're gonna be able to help me oh
my god oh my god II don't like the
rumbling around it what is all this
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] but
that's what it is
what am I even looking for I don't even
know what it looks like I don't even
know what it smells like hi hi sorry I'm
sorry
it looked like I was that like crotch
height they're not my intention
didn't mean to go face-first into your
crotch not my intention
maybe I need to pay more close attention
to to the crumble Wombles oh boy okay oh
well I guess I can hide in that if we
really want to do okay okay okay all
right what do we got here what do we got
what do we got would have got I think I
think the trick is I just got to move
quickly find whatever the hell and look
why oh what's the purpose huh
what was the point of that
okay I guess we're just screaming at me
huh is that what we're doing oh that
looks interesting
Oh found uh found a cool glitch that I
can exploit for speedruns that's nice
all right what do we have here sure over
there's not a monster in here but this
seems to be something handy-dandy aah
okay all right I like it I like it still
don't know what I'm doing but I like it
am i looking for the red pillows I'm
looking for anything good for a brain
there's nothing in here wait what was
even the point of coming in here there's
no way out I can't even get through the
oh why did I find a key what's the key
for
what could keep possibly before you
don't even tell me I don't even know
what in the world I'm at a loss and I'm
nowhere near those guys not anymore
anyway
holy [ __ ] there's one
okay oh there's another there's another
okay okay here all right okay
close close thank you all right I don't
know what I'm looking for me okay okay
don't know what I'm looking for yeah but
I'm not gonna find it yeah all right
okay
oh that's not helpful okay if I could if
you could just stop honking around yeah
so many big boxes no time boxes oh oh
okay
totally fine what's that wait hang on we
got a box under we got a box under the
boxes that's perfect I love box ception
here what nothing there's a whole lot of
nothing it's a coffin that I can put
myself in somebody bury me I'm ready to
die
okay all right keep going I guess what
am I looking what am I looking for
[Music]
looking for I have no idea
oh man I am at a complete loss I have no
idea what I'm doing I have no idea why I
would be doing it in the first place
and I have a key that goes to what what
does it go
I saw something there's something
glowing there oh dear oh it's a gear
it's a gear it's a gear all right maybe
I'm faster than these guys right I'm
faster so if I just go for it
oh there's another one
[Music]
no yes okay if I just go for it okay all
right we're gonna be like that huh what
if what if what if what if that's caught
on something is that caught on your
Tootsie little [ __ ] problem oh that
seems to be an issue let me get out of
here all right I don't know what I'm
doing I don't know how to do this oh
[ __ ] well I'm okay taking this nice and
easy all right all right I don't know
what to do I'm at a loss I can't exactly
just run this out how hidden would these
things be Oh like the entire difficult
whoa
never mind I guess they're not that
hidden so there's a way to fight like I
could find him I guess I could actually
try man but the thing is like just doing
this through sheer whoa oh that that's
the locked door maybe I can at the very
least at the very least I could get that
key and open the locked door right I
could do that I know how to do that I
think anyway I think it was over here
yeah okay here comes that
not sure why not sure why but if I can
get the key then at the very least I can
try to open that door man is it not here
oh it's not here is it [ __ ] ah the keys
in a random place of course it is of
course it would be god damn it
well I have no idea where the key would
be no thanks I just took a piss that was
very important to me I'm glad I'm glad I
did that
why why why no oh [ __ ] all right I can't
do this
there's no way how in the flyff dicken
world would you do this well Bing bong
Bing bong go shove it up your dong dong
with it so anyway that is wake up
brother
yes bros not gonna wake up anytime soon
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to play this for
yourself and try to beat it I'll put a
link to it in the description below I
believe the game is free so it's not too
bad so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always
in the next video
[Music]